i'm guessing you're um quite content
this morning how significant is this
result for you
well good morning kay it's hugely
significant uh this is the largest
majority ever overturned in a
by-election in british history so it's a
huge victory for the liberal democrats
we're very excited but it's a big issue
for our country i think the people of
tifton the huntington have spoken for
the british people and i think they've
said loud and clear that boris johnson
must go when we were talking to people
on the doorsteps they do see him as a
lying law breaker
and they see him as someone who doesn't
have a plan for our country
uh that's suffering and the the the
chaos and the cost of living crisis with
an nhs that that isn't getting properly
supported so liberal democrats put our
positive message to people they backed
us in their droves
and i think they want me to come onto
your program and say to the government
boris johnson must go
just to clarify you said it was the
largest election by election
um overturned result a majority in in
living history that's not right is it
the biggest majority that's ever been
overturned the largest majority of them
no against the tories not not not
completely
uh um i i my figures are what i've just
given you uh kay it's a huge victory we
can quibble about the size if you like
but it's a no no no i'm just clarifying
for you labour's majority was higher at
glasgow governor brent east glasgow
hamilton in 1967 ashfield in 1977. so
we'll give it to you that it's the
biggest largest touring majority that's
ever been overturned in a by-election
but certainly not the largest ever
majority nevertheless
we are where we are how surprised are
you
well i was a bit surprised
on the doorstep it did feel uh very good
for us we were being told by lifelong
conservatives that they thought boris
johnson was not a decent man
uh that he was letting down our country
and i listened to aleister campbell your
previous inter interviewee and i have to
say some of what we were hearing on the
doorstep was exactly what mr campbell
was saying people have lost trust in
boris johnson they see him as dishonest
and they see him as someone who's
incompetent who is unable to come up
with the policies that the country needs
i mean there are millions of people
millions of families millions of
pensioners who are really struggling out
there they're having real problems
paying for their food bills uh problems
paying to they can't even afford to fill
up their their car with petrol
this is a crisis for many people
and people were angry on the doorsteps
and i share that anger when we have a
government that is so incompetent
and if conservative mps don't wake up i
think in the next election uh the voters
will send them packing
by-election uh voting is generally
protest voting though isn't it it's not
always we don't always see it when it
comes to a general election if we did
you'd have a significantly uh bigger
number of seats in the house of commons
than you do at the moment
well over the last year k uh liberal
democrats beat the conservatives in true
blue buckinghamshire in the cheshire
ambition by election about a year ago
then six months later in north
shropshire seat the tourist held for 200
years the liberal democrats beat the
conservatives then we had an amazing set
of local elections where we were the
clear winner where we took uh councils
off the conservatives in somerset in
cumbria we beat them in wimbledon in
woking across the country
and then here today
in east devon we've beaten the
conservatives this isn't a flash in the
pan
this is a series of
victories for the liberal democrats
against conservatives and the last time
this happened was in the mid 1990s and
what happened at the subsequent election
the conservatives lost and were defeated
and were out of power for a long time i
think the liberal democrats are are
leading the way are with a positive
agenda of a tax cut to help people
struggling the vat cut which will uh
reduce inflation help people with their
food bills that sort of positive agenda
is part of showing that there's an
alternative to conservatives we could be
governed far better and i think this
series of by-election victories by the
liberal democrats
may well uh
foretell and come ahead of a tory loss
of the next election where boris johnson
does go and is left and the tour is
defeated
sorry i interrupted you that i said but
um even with these two massive results
of late which no one can take away from
you it still only takes you to 13 mps
doesn't it there's very little you can
do within the chamber of the house of
commons to make any difference to this
prime minister
well first of all okay let me uh correct
you on your figures it's 14 liberal
democrat mp congratulations well done
we're incredibly with each other
but in terms of your point um
listen you're right the concerto mps
hold the future of the prime minister in
their hand and the question is are
conservative mps going to listen to the
people of tiverton and honeton are they
going to listen to the people of north
shropshire are they going to listen to
the people cheshire and amisham
all of whom told us that boris johnson
should go
and if conservative mps don't get the
message they have the power to dispatch
this prime minister if they don't do
that
i think the voters will reap their
revenge it's been really clear
that voters now think the conservative
party is tainted by boris johnson and
the fact that conservative mps won't do
the decent thing won't listen to people
means that they will pay the price of
the next election
uh you keep being very um kind in your
words about uh the labour party are we
gonna see you guys getting together
no no listen uh i keep being asked this
there's no deal there's no pact and
hypothetical questions
are not for today you know the reality
is we need a government that is going to
put the interest of british people first
there are millions of pensioners and
families who are really struggling out
there we need a coherent alternative
plan liberal democrats are putting one
forward with our vat tasker with our
proposals to help people here in devon
with extending the the rural rural fuel
duty
relief scheme we've got these practical
policies which will really help people
and i think we need a political debate
at the next election and a government
that's going to dispatch this awful
conservatives and actually tackle
people's problems